[Applause]
so so disney
is like yo we're pulling out of georgia
right now i was pulling out that we got
into this okay that's right piece of
[ __ ] mark
piece of garbage yeah we pulled out of a
week of work mark
mark i swear to god okay so
they go yo we're pulling out if you guys
keep this bill going right
because they're taking a moral high
ground you know as
most companies do because corporations
are super woke and there's in no way
any hypocrisy attached to a corporation
leave their activism they really are
truly about that life
so they also happen to be making this
movie mulan
are you familiar with mulan i am
familiar with the cartoon mulan
yes it's like chinese joan of arc yes
right
does she pretend to be a guy too yep yep
really
yeah easier for her
i didn't do anything all right well you
guys burned everything
so back to it so they are making this
movie now mark where are they making
this movie
it's a live action version of of the
cartoon where are they making certain
scenes were filmed
in china they were filling in china
interesting and where in china maybe the
shin zoo
region yep and now the shin zoo region i
don't know if you're familiar with it
i'm unfamiliar okay
let me just tell you because i was
completely unfamiliar too okay and i'm
sure disney had no clue
they're not making this movie by any way
to pander to the chinese movie market
which is a
you know huge movie market now there's
no way are they doing that they're just
recreating movies that they really like
yeah
you care about absolutely 100 no dollar
signs attached to this at all none
let's do the writing well shin zhu is
home to
a group of chinese muslims called the
uyghurs
oh have you heard of them i have heard
of them well you got to hear about them
now because they're going extinct
china's getting rid of them okay adios
putting them in concentration camps
can you imagine the levels of
concentration coming out
of a chinese concentration camp
bro taylor
see how distracted you are right now
because you're high
you're playing attention exactly
the point is the point is you use for
one on sentences right now
you know you're a really brilliant
idiot's tailor today you know you need
to bring black flagrant
concentrate yo you need to concentrate
listen you need to concentrate because
it's a choice
there are some parts of the world where
you got to concentrate because you're
chinese because you're chinese man
real talk they got them in concentration
camps wild
i know ripping them off the streets
removing their religion
removing their rights how could they
possibly film a movie in a place
where people's rights are being stripped
and their lives taken away and they're
free to be
i'm sure they didn't know this probably
isn't a move like a news story that
anybody knows about
right it was probably super nuanced or
something very nuanced you know i hear
you
yeah i'm sure the news hides this kind
of thing yeah yeah you know what you're
probably right you're probably right
about that but it
is shocking that a corporation would do
this it's it is
shocking absolutely shocking i
personally always have good faith in
corporations
yo i mean they're moral people moral
that their bottom line
is to morality and activism not to their
shareholders
absolutely right absolutely kind of
absolutely
are we losing the game are we locked in
the game
what is it that responsibility what did
they say the corporation's uh
uh responsibility is always to the
shareholder yes or something like that
that's what i was talking about
obviously we're being sarcastic and this
is once again absolutely
ridiculous and these [ __ ] celebs are
absolutely ridiculous and
performative oakness same things happen
in hollywood right now did you see like
the new uh
uh the new requirements to to have like
an oscar
oh your requirements to have an emmy you
have to do this like it has to be
super like diverse cast and all this
other kind of [ __ ] what i don't
understand is why the performative
[Applause]
action
you